today we're looking at Logitech's G 303
Daedalus apex gaming mouse if it looks
familiar that's because it's nearly
identical to the G 302 Logitech's MOBA
centric mouse that was released just a
few months ago while the two-day list
mice look the same they're actually
quite different under the hood the
advantage going to the apex the apex is
picsart 3366 sensor tops out at 12,000
dpi in addition to its fine grain
sensitivity this new laser is fast
capable of accurately detecting movement
at 300 inches per second pic starts new
laser can also be found a logitech g502
mouse aka the Proteus core which while
being ten dollars more expensive than
the dallas apex also comes with more
buttons and a larger chassis from a
technical perspective the Daedalus apex
is a great mouse but your appreciation
for its form factor will come down to
personal preference with a high back and
low wedged front it's ideal for people
that grip their mice with their fingers
rather than by applying pressure with
their palm at a hair over 3 ounces it's
also incredibly nimble where most mouse
buttons tend to feel alike the buttons
on Daedalus mice are distinctly light
and quick on the draw making it easy to
rapidly press either button it's a
feeling that takes some getting used to
but once you're familiar and comfortable
with these buttons other mice feel stiff
and slow by comparison if you aren't a
fan of complicated in bulky mice I can't
recommend the Daedalus apex enough it's
light comfortable and even though it's a
little expensive at seventy dollars at
least you're getting a mouse with one of
the best sensors on the market
you